[Music]
chair we're now live on youtube
good morning and welcome to team bridge
district council's virtual planning
committee
on tuesday the 13th of april 2021
i am your chair mike haynes
as this is the first team bridge council
meeting since the death
of his royal highness the prince philip
duke of edinburgh
please join me in a minute of quiet
reflection
on his life of great service to our
nation and for her majesty of the queen
and members of the royal family
at this time of their sad loss
thank you all participants here today
are taking part remotely
and the committee is being viewed online
and recorded so please bear this in mind
throughout the meeting in the event of a
break in the internet connection
or power cut please bear with us as we
try to reconnect
if we are not able to reconnect after 15
minutes
the meeting will be adjourned and
reconvened at a later date
please check the committee page on our
website for further details
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you are not speaking
to avoid any background noise levels
please keep your point
short and do not interrupt when someone
is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic yellow hand
and wait to be called all councillors
have been sent the agenda for today's
meeting
any members of the public who want to
view the agenda can do so
by visiting our website teambridge.gov
dot uk i will now start the committee by
doing a roll call
of everyone here present when you hear
your name
please confirm by saying present
chris can you do that please thank you
chair councillor bradford
essence
[Music]
mcgregor
your mu counsellor president thank you
um
councillor nuttall
council and ettel
is yeah counselor you it will turn me
[Music]
all right because i'm not all i think
i can say can you please confirm your
present
uh we'll come back to counselor national
um councillor nutley
councillor patch president councillor
parker's given his apologies
um councillor goodman bradbury
president and councillor haines
present um there seemed to have been a
note i think from
councillor natal um
yes thanks chair my my internet was very
unstable for a moment i missed
i missed the roll call but i seem to be
connected back again now so i'm here
thank you right thank you um
can i now introduce the members of the
offices who are
in attendance today uh we have ian perry
the principal planning officer kelly
grunell
senior planning officer steve hobbs
enforcement officer
suzanne walford solicitor
chris morgan trainee democratic services
officer
and trish corn's democratic services
officer
i also note on my screen we have the
drainage and coastal manager
who will be introduced himself on the
item later
thank you we could move on then to
the agenda item one apologies for
abstinence please chris
um apologies received from councillor
parker chair
thank you no others
okay second item is the minutes of the
meeting the last meeting of the 16th of
march
which are with the agenda um does anyone
wish to
raise any issues relating to their
correctness
uh when somebody like to move there
agreed thank you
councillor bullivan's hand and council
mcgregor i've gone up
um can i have a show of hands please to
show a cent
thank you i think that that's
agreed thank you on to
item three declarations of interest are
there any members wishing to
declare an interest
okay nobody's indicated if anything
arises during the meeting you suddenly
realize then obviously you can still let
us know then
item four chairman's announcements the
only thing i would say of course is that
as things currently stand
we are due to meet again as a committee
on the 18th
of may which is after the
next phase in the roadmap and as things
currently stand
that would have to be physically
at the council chamber because the
government of course is
not continuing the regulations or the
legislation there is an appeal pending
on that so we'll know
by later this month so i look forward to
seeing you if that's the way it is but
we'll have to take
uh steps to ensure that it's um code
secure if that's what we have to do and
obviously
not entirely happy about it being
perhaps premature but just watch this
space
members okay
item five public participation there is
one public speaker today on major
applications so that
person will have five minutes to speak
item six is the planning applications
for
consideration uh that's the first one
there is
trade winds at timmouth and
um i believe that's uh ian perry or
taking us through this one yeah thank
you chairman
morning everyone um let me just get my
screen up and running
for you okay
right so our first application today uh
is a detached dwelling that sits on
the corner of upper hermosa road
and
sorry just bear with me upper hermosa
road and yannon drive
so just here for context if you're not
sure
where about some timothy is uh it's the
uh
house there with the green box around it
for context you've got the timber
community
uh school in this location here extra
road
runs to the uh east and
obviously you can see the river team
there and the den down there so it's
it's
essentially just out of town uh but
relatively central to
uh the middle of timothy so
we've got like i say a detached dwelling
which sits
on a slight hill so well say slight hill
is quite a big hill
um which runs uh downwards from north to
south
um so
in terms of what it looks like at
present we've got the house down in the
bottom left there
and just peeking out you can see my
cursor there
is a little portion of flat roof if you
view it from the other side
from yannon drive you can see the flat
roof here
and what we're proposing essentially is
a pitch roof over the top of that
existing flat roof
there's a few external alterations as
well
so we've got the doors at uh ground
floor level
uh raising upwards because there's
internal floor changes happening as well
uh but in essence to those people
walking past on yannon drive
or seeing it from anywhere else the
difference you're gonna notice
is the new pitch roof over the flat roof
and not really anything more than that
there have been objections from the
residents at number 50
and 51 yan and drive their objections
are on the basis of
impact on view they will lose some view
of the nests and the shore down there
as you know in planning terms loss of
view is not a material planning
consideration
in terms of the distances there there's
clearly no impact on outlook
which is a slightly different thing to
view and there's no other immunity
impacts that are considered to exist
so that's the application there's a
minor thing i'd like to point out
in terms of the plans and if you look at
the existing
elevations in photograph you'll see
there's windows
in the gables on both sides which are
not showing
on the elevations on the drawings that
is a
drafting a mission um the
architect has clearly concentrated on
the new parts
and not provided the full detail of what
exists
and because that is an error and there
is an approved planned condition that
goes on every decision
will ensure that that approved plans
condition actually states that the
development is in accordance with the
approved plans
with the exception that the existing
windows
that are there remain in situ we don't
want problems down the line with
solicitors when it comes to sales
and things like that so just for clarity
that will be added to the conditions
um and i think that's all from me chair
okay thank you
right we don't have a world member or
indeed
any timeless members um present at this
meeting
um it's on the agenda today because
obviously it's under reason for report
the applicant
is an elected councillor um i have
and raise i've got a couple um raised
now council bull event
thank you can i propose a set up please
mcgregor
yeah well i would second that um
just just briefly with the addition that
um where the property is situated
there's quite a lot of gap between the
houses the houses above
uh in terms of view they're not really
going to be impacted too much because
they're significantly higher up above
the above the property
and i think we're we're situated on a
corner with roads on two sides
i don't think it's going to have much of
an impact at all so i would move to
second
thank you well i'd be in agreement with
those points so
i'm happy with that does anyone else
wish to speak okay nobody's indicated
so um it's been moved the recommendation
has set out that permission to be
granted with the conditions obviously
slightly varied as uh mr perry outlined
for the
approved drawings so can i ask chris to
go through please and take a recorded
vote
thank you chair councillor bradford
councillor bullavent councillor clarence
bought
councillor jeffrey councillor kurzweil
four councillor mcgregor
or councillor nuttall
i think he's still he's not come back
properly yet
um councillor nutley four four
councillor patch four
uh councillor goodman bradbury
and councillor haynes
um can i just double check if because
the knuckle was here i heard
a noise not sure if that was him voting
or not can't see him on the screen
he's got his camera turned off at the
moment
okay okay thank you so i think that's
unanimous christmas yeah that's
unanimous chair
thank you so approval is um granted as
set out thank you all right if we can
move on to
the second application under item six
which is the
uh my camera seems to have gone off
sorry
that's what i was trying to find you
know so that's all i must have pressed
the wrong button
um item 6b is the
application in star cross we have
um a public speaker on this one so
please could you
admit the speaker to the meeting
okay i can see that the supporter
is on the list and
has turned his camera on now
um yep okay so
we can proceed um to the supporter we'll
have the presentation from the officer
first and then
i'll invite you to speed after that
thank you okay
um kelly please you're going to take us
through this one
thank you um ian would you be able to
enable my screen sharing function please
sorry kelly um that was my fault you
should be able to do it now
thank you very much
thank you okay this is a revised
application
for the erection of 20 affordable houses
and includes a replacement a new local
area of
quick play um public open space
landscaping and access
at brickyard lane in star cross
before i go through the presentation i
just wanted to
update members on um
an error in the report so if i refer you
to
section 2 paragraph 2.1
0.7 on the list of obligations in the
section 106 agreement
we refer to the provisional offsite
works and the offsite works will only be
drawing
sk04 rev a and don't include
sk05 rev a that was removed when the
scheme was reduced
from 32 to 20 units and that change is
set out in the report
thank you okay
okay so the site is on the western edge
of the starcroft settlement so we can
see
the up area here and we can see the site
here
it's at the south side of brickyard lane
and to the west of parkers road which is
a built-up housing area
it's opposite the driveway with hayward
drive
and we can see to the far east the a379
and then beyond this we've got the river
x and then down here to the south we
have staff lake lane
and again just an aerial view of the
site so we can see it more in context we
can see
the built up area star cross and then we
can see it's on the immediate
outer edge of the settlement
and i guess in terms of the more
immediate site it's 0.9 hectares
it's bordered by trees and hedgerow to
the east
and we can see down here to the parkers
road development as well
there's a locally equipped area of play
here which is a local authority play
area
as well as a small informal kick about
area
and then there as we sat in the report
there's an oak tree which sits
here at the roadside with brickyard lane
a stream runs from um along
the boundary here along this hedge line
all the way through where the park is
and then we as we sat in the report the
northeastern corner where the existing
play area in kickabout zone
is located within flood zone two and
three
and is within the settlement limit of
star cross
and the remainder of the sky is outside
the settlement limit and also outside of
the blood zone
here we see the block plan proposed for
the site so we can see the um the
application is made by templar homes
which is part of teen housing a
registered social provider
um a plan permission is sought for 20
affordable dwellings which comprises a
mix of 14 rented and six shares
and we set out in the report that we'll
use the standard cascade which will be
in the
section 106 agreement which will be the
housing will be delivered to starcross
first
then secondary area of manhattan kenton
and dawlish and then
tertiary areas in winder team bridge
after that
so access will be taken from brickyard
lane
um so we can see it here so where the
existing play area is here
the access will come through here and
then what we will see is a replacement
leap provided here which will be in a
quick play area
and then we've got two more in formal
areas of play either side
um sub scheme is provided in the form of
underground surface water attenuation
and that's shown here
we've got a three metre ecological
buffer to be provided around the
perimeter of the site
we can see that in dark green here
we've also got a detailed landscape
scheme which i'll show you on the
following
slide and then there's a the provision
of the non-signal pedestrian crossing
at new road close to star cross primary
school
so in terms of the landscape scheme in
the report we talk about the
regrettable loss of the oak tree which
sits here
what is proposed as a compensation
package as part of the application
is a range of landscaping measures
including
replacement oak trees which we see here
circled in red as well as
four at the access road and then a
larger specimen will be replaced
at the roadside
and these are just some elevations
within the sites we have an idea of what
the development may look like
so the predominant character in the area
is
two-story semis or townhouses so
that's very much reflected in the design
most properties have a clear divide
between
ground and first floor and so this has
been used to reflect local character
but the applicant has proposed to
incorporate some render and some tar
hanging and cladding to just offer some
originality to the development as well
we've talked a lot in the report about
the option agreement
and the removal and the replacement of
the play area
which would be here we have
recommended in the report that the
provision of the play equipment is
provided by a condition and i've just
listed at the side
um some of the agreed equipment that we
would expect to come
forward and this can be incorporated in
the condition if required
and so we can see that we'd have a
cradle swing a base wing
a toddler's multi-play area so there
would this has been agreed with
the council's play project officer
again in the report we talk about the
provision
of a emergency access route
being incorporated within the section
106 agreement and we can see this here
so
it run down the site here along the
existing hedge boundary so we can see it
here in aerial view
and just to have an understanding how
that may be incorporated through the
development
it would come through the existing spine
road and then down
and again just to illustrate where the
offside works
are the starcross school is here there's
an existing crossing here and then we'd
have a
an informal crossing provided here so
that children
from the new development accessing the
site as well as a benefit to
other children in the local community
would have another crossing point
here and then just a couple of photos of
the site
so this is the oak tree this is hayward
drive which is almost immediately
opposite where the proposed
junction would be provided is here and
then the site sits behind here
and then this is looking at the site
from hayward drive so we can again see
the tree
we can see the existing play area this
is the parkers road properties
the existing willow tree that you may
have seen in some of the landscape
drawings
and then the access that will be created
almost opposite hayward drive
and this is just an image of the
existing player area so if you don't
know the area you will
have an idea of what equipment will be
removed and then re-replaced with new
elsewhere within the site
this is just the context so the site
lies adjacent to the parker's road
properties and then this is the willow
tree
there's an existing green lane that
separates the residential development
from the site
and then we've got hedgerow and then the
site sits next to this
and then this is just within the site so
stood in the field
looking towards brickyard lane you can
see the existing trees
and then the play park is sat here in
this corner
and then these are just looking towards
stop lake lane
so this is where the emergency access
route would be taken and we're stood on
the site here
again we can see how much screening
there is around the existing site
and then this is on the site looking
back towards parker's road so again we
see the existing willow
the play parks here and then there's
this is the existing parker's road
development and again looking back
towards the site
um we're on brickyard lane haywood drive
oak tree and then we've got the site in
here with the player behind
we can also see here the width of the
road and we can see the presence of some
on-street parking
but still with some spaces available for
cars to
maneuver down the road and these are
just some photos to show the site again
we've got the green lane here so this is
the opposite end of parker's road
we can just see that it's currently a
field and there will be a presence of
housing there
and these are just some long views just
to really say from places like state
lake lane
you you'll see glimpses of the
development but will very much sit
within the current urban context of the
star cross settlement
um and then this is the site from you
wrote from around about where the school
is again
the site wouldn't be very visible and it
would just sit with the existing
development
and again just to give some context to
the off-site works that we've referred
to this is where they would be so we've
got the school here
and a crossing point would be created
here so it would provide an additional
safe space for children to cross when
they're accessing the school
and therefore you'll see in the report
there's an officer recommendation to
approve
subject to the conditions and the
obligations set out in the report
thank you chairman okay thank you kelly
um
right if i could um now invite the
public speaker supporter to speak i did
mute you earlier on because
um i had a couple and also i muted
counseling not all um because it was
popping up on the screen
um so if you're able to unmute yourself
you can't find him now he's unmuted at
the moment
yeah can you hear me cancers yeah i've
got you yeah that's fine
so you've got five minutes um up to five
minutes
from when you start thank you
okay uh thank you chair and members for
this opportunity
to speak on behalf of the applicant
templar homebuild limited
a company owned by teen housing who are
a locally based housing association
with more than 3500 affordable homes in
team bridge
the application has been amended from 32
dwellings of open market
and affordable homes to a 100 affordable
housing development with 20 homes
there's been a significant amount of
discussion with statutory council cheese
and officers regarding the proposals
who have left no stone unturned to
ensure that all technical matters have
been satisfactorily addressed
there are no objections from these
statutory councils or officers and the
parish council also raises no objection
dealing with the main issues there is a
proven need for affordable housing from
households who have a strong connection
with the parish
in this regard the proposals comply with
policy we5
for rural exception sites the officer's
report affords the provision of 20
affordable homes very substantial weight
the loss of the oak tree at the site
frontage is regrettable
we have explored alternative options
with devon county highways but there is
just not sufficient frontage with the
road to retain
the tree as mitigation 35 replacement
trees are proposed with numerous shrubs
and landscaping this includes a new
group of oak trees close to the entrance
to the site
including larger than normal specimen
specimen trees known as heavy standards
there is about 180 meters of new native
species hedge
and a wildlife corridor around the
perimeter of the site
overall the proposals achieve a
biodiversity net
gain on ecology numerous discussions
with natural england and the council's
ecologists have taken place who are
content that the proposals protect
notable bird species and bats
and all other species for that matter
the proposals
provide a newly equipped play area which
is an increase of 144 square meters
compared to the existing play area which
is a 26
increase so just over a quarter of the
size bigger
in addition a further 1288 meter square
of informal play space provides an
attractive landscape environment for the
new houses
and for the general public to use
importantly
the new play areas are outside of the
flood zone whereas the existing
play area has a history of flooding or
at least it's within the flood zone
the local lead flood authority agrees
that the proposals
appropriately attenuate surface water so
that the development will not cause
flooding elsewhere
although the site is not in a flood zone
currently an emergency access route has
been safeguarded in the unlikely event
that sea defenses are not renewed in the
future
some concern has been raised about
transport impacts however the proposed
20 dwellings would not generate
noticeable levels of traffic and county
highways have raised no objection
the new pedestrian crossing facilities
proposed a new road in front of
starcross primary school
in conclusion the development would
deliver 20 quality affordable homes
as well as the other benefits that i
have described
the office of report gives significant
weight to these benefits
and whilst clearly the loss of the
infantry is a disbenefit
the benefits are considered to outweigh
the harm caused
i hope that members will agree and
support the officer's recommendation for
approval
thank you chair and members thank you
right councillor collett is the ward
member and he's asked to speak on this
item so i could invite you to speak next
please council college
thank you uh chairman
um colleagues um this is uh
an application as as you've heard for
100 affordable housing in stylecross
which is
badly needed but it is a solomon
application in the sense that there are
very many objections from local
residents to it for a number of reasons
and not least the loss of that very
significant oak tree
i entirely accept uh the officer report
and indeed the comments of the
supporter that all has been done to try
and protect that tree by
looking at it through new light with
highways to see whether
new junction arrangements can be arrived
at and the
the fact of the matter is that it is
just not possible
and that will be a very sad loss uh for
star cross but the significant benefit
are the 20 affordable homes 14 rented
and six shared ownership
i think it's important to note as well
that the priority
of allocation gives first priority to
star cross
although i would like the officers to
note that the neighboring parish also
includes
product uh in addition to kenton and
dawlish and i think powder should be
included in the second gatekeeper for
the cascade
um i do ask officers if you could just
clarify
what is referred to as the uh proposed
crossing point that's
star cross primary school that would be
provided
the existing one isn't a zebra crossing
or a light control crossing it's a
there's a raised thump in the road
uh with painted children's feet marks
to indicate there's a safe place to
cross
and although i appreciate the proposed
crossing is not going to be like
controlled
i'm not entirely clear from all of the
descriptions what it is apart from some
dropped curves so be really hopeful if
officers could explain
what that is so residents are very clear
when the planning officer spoke at the
start of the presentation chairman
they referred to a paragraph or section
two
2.1.7 and this is about withdrawing
uh drawings sk08 rev a
and sk05 rev a i wasn't entirely sure
what that actually meant so if
members of the public are viewing the
the
planning committee i'm not sure they
know what it is that
shouldn't have been in there what's come
out so if officers could explain
what that is that would be really
helpful
chairman the application has been with
the council for some long time and i
think teen housing
uh the council and the statutory
organizations
have done a huge amount to overcome the
concerns
or to at least mitigate the concerns of
many residents regarding flooding and
the number of issues
i've rarely seen a report like this
which identifies so clearly the
anxieties that local residents have
raised
and what has been done to mitigate it
originally of course there were 32 homes
uh to be
applied for and that has been reduced to
20 wholly affordable with no
uh private element to it and that does
go a long way to meet the numbers uh
there is capacity um
locally at the school uh from devon
county council's point of view
and at the surgery the nhs are not
seeking contribution
uh chairman overall or on balance uh i
think the
applicants have gone a long way to meet
the concerns of a local community
although i readily acknowledge very many
residents
will be upset at the loss of the oak
tree and feel the concern that we are
building on land just behind
parker's road brickyard lane in an area
which is known to be used by
birds but you will have seen the report
of natural england
uh and the mitigations that have been
put in place
and i think chairman i've said all i
need to say in terms of representing the
voice
of residents both those that wish to
secure
a new affordable home and those that are
concerned
by the proposal thank you very much
chairman
thank you if i could ask kelly to
come back with detail on the um specific
issues raised so it's the detail of the
crossing
and also um the plans i presume they'll
be available
um online but it's a job looking for
them
in in 2.1.7 kelly i
thank you chairman um my screen is my
screen's still sharing
no no it's um
okay let's see
that's it
thank you chairman so this is the slide
that i um previously
uh showed regarding the proposed
off-site works
so it will take the form of a drop curb
and tactile paving
and what we also have is the street
light will be really
relocated back and you can see here
along this first line
the width of the current footpath so the
streetlight will be moved back and the
footpath will also be
slightly increased in width and that
would allow i guess
freer and safer movement along that path
part of the site as well
in terms of the sk05 that was for
another road
where other off side site roadworks were
proposed i don't have that plan
available at the moment it is online
but that was when we were looking at a
32 unit
scheme and devon county council advised
that
with the 12th dwelling reduction it was
no longer required which is why it was
removed and we do set that out
in the beginning proposal section of the
report
thank you thank you okay okay you go
back to full screen now please
thank you okay um we did have a site
inspection as this is a major
um so i'll go through the members of the
site inspection team to give their views
on
what they could see on site clearly only
some of those issues would be what's
in the agenda uh so it's councillor
bullivant
councilmember kurzweil and myself so
council bolivar please
thank you um i think the site visit
showed
the depth of thinking that had gone on
in terms of how this site can be
developed suitably
and whilst the oak tree and the loss of
the oak tree would be a
sad thing to see the compensatory
planting that
is proposed i think goes a long long way
to
mitigating the impact of that loss of
the oak tree
in terms of the delivery of the 20
affordable homes i think that's the
important
thing for the people of star crossing or
glaring
and i i welcome the s106 requirement to
guarantee access to those buildings for
those
those people an area of concern or two
areas of concern i have
that won't stop me
recommending approval of this site but
in terms of the
area allocated the current area for play
on that site it is a high quality
council maintained facility
that's a a very high specification
compared to some of the other sites
we're seeing
coming through new developments that we
have i am concerned that the report
refers
back to the fact that the list of
equipment provided
is as per the minimum acceptable
standard
currently uh specified by team bridge
and i understand that uh templar have
said they will replace
like for like the existing equipment
which is much higher standard that we're
currently seeing on some of our new
developments
so i'd like some assurance that that can
can be put into the
approval document that the equipment
that will be provided
will be certainly no
lower standard than that than that
currently provided
also the surface treatment of the area
is high quality at the moment and i am
concerned that some of the comments when
you read through the reports
um refer or do not detail how the
surface treatment of the play area is
going to be
covered further the current area is
surrounded by a safety fence
for the children playing there to keep
them safe in their area
and again reading through the report
pages 54
53 54 55
refers to the boundary treatments and
there is no mention of the safety
fence and if you look at the planting
that's planned
there is a herbaceous border between the
play area
and the road and there's no obvious
access points or no obvious gates or
anything else although it refers to in
different
sections of the report so i'd like
clarity on what is actually intended
there and i'd certainly recommend that a
safety fence
is included around the play area to stop
children potentially running across the
road
to go to the open areas of play
um so i'd like clarification i think we
ought to be
asking that we take photographs of the
existing
um play area such that there's a
standard that people can refer back to
for
comparison with any new facilities
provided
i also noted that the plans include
or specify that the new replacement play
area would be available
no later than 18 months after the site
is acquired by
templar that basically implies that the
area will lose a play area for
18 months is there anything that can be
done to ensure that
the loss of that player is minimized
um further when you read through the
report i think page 56 page 57
you'll see that the local
officer providing homes where they're
talking about the provision
of building um two plots or two
requirements to have two plots available
for self build
his recommendation is that this refuse
is turned down because of that but
there's no
mention of why that recommendation has
not been addressed within the report
so i'm happy that the 20 i'm happy that
there is no building cost provided but
like some expedition as to why
that comment hasn't been addressed
within the report having said those
things i'm very happy with the quality
report i think it goes to a hell of a
lot of detail
it gives the assurances that we
basically need and i will certainly be
recommending that it is pass for
approval thank you
thank you um on that point about the
um self build i think that was for the
larger
number i'll get kelly to come in and
address
your points perhaps at this stage kelly
uh thank you chairman and thank you for
your comments counselor bulovan
uh yes in terms of the the play
um space in terms of hard and soft
landscaping
boundary treatments and the play
equipment it is proposed
that we agree this by condition and then
ongoing maintenance would be
included within the section 106
agreement um you are correct that they
haven't been agreed yet but
the i i don't think you can see the
slide at the moment let me just sort of
uh screen share so you can see the slide
but the slide that you can see at the
moment the list you see on the left hand
side is what has been
requested by our play project officer
debbie marshall so
um she's asked for this as a minimum so
you see that it is intended that the
play area would be bound by bow top
fencing which is similar to what they've
got at present
and then we'd probably agree where the
uh access points into the park are
as part of the whole scheme coming
forward and they would be
discussed with our project play officer
and the difficulty here is we've
obviously got
the option agreement where the local
authorities are saying
what the minimum is they require to
satisfy the auction agreement
and which would be like for like
replacement of all equipment there and
if they don't do that they don't satisfy
your option agreement
so they have to do that outside of
planning to meet the terms of the legal
agreement and then on top of that
we have our own policy we11 where we
will require them to provide
additional formal play as part of this
application so we certainly will be
addressing all the points that you've
raised
um through the condition
and again in terms of what you said
about the custom build officers
points you are cracks that um the
original 32 unit
scheme was liable to provide
custom build housing because it was
above 20 units
but when the scheme was reduced to 20
there was no longer requirement to
provide any custom build units on site
thank you chairman thank you thank you
chair i'm content although i would point
out that the requirement for self build
is
20 plus and as the report says that
uh it is 20
on page 55 it does say that um will be
secure anyway i'm content with the reply
and i thank kelly for that
okay thank you for going back thank you
councilman
as well thank you chairman um
yes i was the other counsellor who came
with you on that site inspection
and councillor bullock i really can't
add very much
at all to what counselor bullaman has
said
because he's been very thorough um
i did i did think that it was a superb
site for affordable housing in as much
as it was completely level
and it
it's so good to see that teen housing
are going to build affordable houses for
local people i was also pleased to see
that
when we were talking about the play area
as councillor bulovant
has said the equipment that is there at
the moment
is of good quality and apparently um
star cross will be able to take that
equipment
and use it elsewhere so i was delighted
to see that that was being recycled
um and i will also approve this
recommendation thank you thank you
um well i was the other member of the
site inspection team i don't really have
a great deal to add
uh as an exception site for affordable
housing for local affordable housing i
saw this as being
obviously a good site um the concerns
about the
impact on tree and other wildlife
mitigation
uh in other circumstances might have
been
um sort of things that would have to
have been taken into account
with more weight but on balance on this
occasion i agree with the officer's
um analysis of the different factors so
i i will be
supporting this myself in fact i'll i'll
move the recommendation
um which is fairly lengthy that members
have got at the start of this item so
that we've got
that clearly in front of us uh would
somebody like to
second that yeah it's been seconded by
council of wolverine
thank you i've got a couple of speakers
now
um councillor hook
thank you chair um um i was unable to
come on the site visit so i apologize
for that i was working that day
um i don't know the site terribly well
um
as a consequence but um can see
um i've looked at the report and the
photos etc
um i mean i also would like to um
credit the report and its detailed
nature so that really does help us have
a real insight into the
um considerations that have gone into
this application
um and i just had a few questions really
looking at someone um
looking at the issues and not knowing
the site
fully um with regard to
the site that's chosen in a way so what
i'm seeing is a big
field um and part of that field having
been chosen for a housing development
and yet when i look at access points
other potential access points
i see um an access from a road called
meadow view which comes from parker's
road
um which is the existing developed area
which
which looks like it was designed as a
road to access that field for future
development
and so you know looking at that i think
why
is that not accessing into a different
section of the field
to develop i mean there may be a very
obvious answer
and then i'm also looking and seeing
about this um
flood access road that will potentially
be put in place in the future
thinking why can't that be the access
now
the permanent access to this development
which would result in the saving of the
oak tree
and the saving of the existing play area
and hopefully the improvement of that
existing play area
so that that was two two questions i had
um
with regard to the tree i mean i think
the report has correctly identified
the two items to which we should give
substantial weight
and that is obviously the provision of
20 affordable dwellings
and i i couldn't have imagined a
situation where i would ever have
spoken against the provision of 20
affordable dwellings but i find myself
really torn on this one
because i i have been reading around a
lot
on the subject of veteran and ancient
trees and their incredible ecological
value um something i hadn't been aware
of before
um and just to remind us if this tree is
300 years old
it was um 1721.
think of all the things that tree has
survived um and now we're actually going
to plan
to destroy it so you know i don't
usually get emotional about
things like that but you know i thought
um i've ought to speak up on behalf of
this tree um because i think that is a
thing we should
give significant weight to and if there
are alternative
ways to develop this site or slightly
alternative
bits of the site that can be developed
then you know i personally would like
to feel reassured that this really is
the only
option available to us um because we
have plenty of local plan policies that
i could pick out
that we could easily refuse this on so
um
you know i i need to be reassured on
that um
and then just on the carbon reduction
issues um
i understand this application was
submitted in 2018
so so it doesn't um doesn't have to
um fulfill the current requirements and
more recent requirements we've
um put in um but i
would like it tightened up when the
condition is written and it may have
been that that was intended anyway
but if we can put something um that
the carbon reduction plan needs to be in
place and agreed before
construction starts on site and to make
sure that it
it actually specifically says it needs
to comply with policy s7
that isn't quite how it's worded there
at the moment so if we can just
um be absolutely sure on that but if i
could have an answer to some of those
sort of query things
thank you kelly
oh thank you councillor hook um yeah
i'll just probably
begin with the easiest response first
in terms of the carbon reduction plan we
have agreed
a condition wording with william elliott
our climate officer and it does include
policy s7
and it does include a time scale
for the measures to be in place so we
have considered those with points we
just didn't put the details in fully
within the report
in terms of access points you are right
the loss of the tree is regrettable and
it has been given considerable
thought throughout the process of the
application which you'll see has been
with the local authority
for around three years um so
first we've looked at other points to
come off brickyard lane let me
i'll screen share and
probably show you my gs if you can see
that
are you able to see my gis yep i can
save that one yeah
yeah so the site is here um in terms of
brickyard lane we can see here the text
saying there's a gasket oven here
so when we looked at alternative options
to move further up brickyard lane it
caused
problems because there would be a need
to then divert pipes
and also obtain um
ownership or permission from a third
party
to come over here so there's a lot of
knowns and also a lot of additional
costs that would which would have made a
100
affordable housing scheme unviable um
the other point that
uh council hook referred to is this road
here so the site is here
so it stops almost opposite um this road
here
in terms of this access point the
um the applicant just doesn't have
the ability to cross over this
third-party land to use this access to
the site
and so it isn't a possibility for them
to obtain access this way although i do
accept
it would be a way to avoid the removal
of the tree and
in terms of the emergency access route
that comes down here
it comes off state lake lane which is
quite a narrow road
and hedge and although i haven't
undertaken consultation with
a highway authority this certainly
is a better route to accommodate the
traffic associated with 20 dwellings
then this is likely to be is anticipated
this would just be immersed
emergency vehicles when there's a flood
event but not for sort of free flow of
traffic from the development
so yeah so i don't think this would be
suitable to encourage the development to
come
down this route and be permanently
accessed this way
okay thank you thank you can you go back
to the
screen then
thank you council bradford
thank you chair um i too am very
concerned about the oak tree
um i
really need to speak up for this tree um
and also there have been 77 letters
of objection um i think ancelott said
that
um a lot of them were concerned about
the tree
um a petition by 29 members of
parker's road and two objections by
cpre um
i i know that affordable housing
is needed but
the planting of new trees won't provide
the same ecosystem
that is benefited by old trees
and there are masses and masses of birds
there the report is um very
very good very um
intricate and it names so many birds
there will also be a lot of light
pollution so i'm very concerned about
that
mitigation just makes something that's
severe
a bit less severe
that's all i've got to say on it okay
cancer not all
uh thank you chair i'd like to pick up
on a concern raised by the rspb
um if you look at the 23 very stringent
planning conditions that are proposed
at the extent complexity and detail of
the proposed construction environmental
management plan
the landscape and ecological management
plan it's clear that this
proposed development is going to have a
potentially substantial negative impact
which is going to require large amounts
of compensation and mitigation my
question is
where is the capacity to manage that
mitigation to ensure that all those
conditions
all those proposals uh in in the um
construction plan and the ecological
plans
are actually delivered thank you
kelly uh thank you councillor nettle
um it was difficult to
summarise three years of ecological work
and background
within the planning committee report but
you might see a
paragraph 3.100 i
i refer to the appropriate assessment
which
natural england have agreed to when we
say that a small number of spa
birds and species were found to roost
and feed on the wider field within which
the site sits
and within adjacent fields however the
loss of this site
in the corner field with the remaining
five hectares of the field continuing to
be available resource
was concluded to have a negligible
impact on the species from the
accessory and then we we have referred
to the rsbb comments but we have also
pointed out that the applicant has
undertaken a whole suite of surveys and
natural england who are the government
authority have raised no objections to
the development
in terms of how we manage that
mitigation you'll see in the report that
we have proposed this goes into the
legal agreement so we're not putting
conditions on
we're putting it into the 106 agreement
so we'll be managed legally
through that process
thank you council natalie
yeah thank you chair yeah i mean in
actual fact some of my
points that i was going to raise has
been mentioned i do echo cancer
hooks and uh bradford's uh
concerns on on the tree and it's a pity
that uh
something can't be uh you know done with
that i mean
you mentioned about this meadow road i'd
say i don't know the area myself
um and i can see at some stage this th
this development will be extended and
i'm just wondering
is it not possible to you know have an
entrance by that better road
um i mean that's one thing the other
thing that i was is which councilman
was more or less brushed on um bottom of
page 52 with the rspb
um concerns and that on that have they
actually done the
surveys they say between october and
november and that
or march rather um have that been done
because obviously the car
buntings concerns about the car buntings
of wildlife in general
and say you know being a twitter should
i say
um i get rather concerned when it
concerns wildlife and especially birds
etc i just
wonder whether the surveys have been
done on those points
thank you
okay uh thank you councillor
um yes um so the applicant has
undertaken a whole suite of
ecological surveys including ecological
impact assessment
and the winter bird survey and they
followed the
recommendations and guidelines set out
by natural england
so they did cover the points raised to
properly assess where the birds were in
the field in the wider field
what birds were present and how they
were using those fields
and the mitigation measures that are now
proposed a part of the application are a
result of those surveys
thank you councillor hook
thank you chair um yeah just on the um
access i mentioned meadowview and um
kelly's answer um that sounded terribly
much like me that she was describing a
ransom strip um
so which is where a third party um
retains a
thin thin piece of land to ask for a lot
of money
um for something to happen basically um
and can she confirm
whether that is the case because um then
we truly know where the blame
for this lies um but um you know the
fact that we couldn't access another
part of the field from
meadowview um but in terms of the um
ecology side of things um
you know i've read through all the um
reports by the various
wildlife organizations you know natural
england rspb devon wildlife trust
and you know they they seem to be
largely content now with obviously
there's a lot of work that's gone into
this and
they do seem to be largely content and
why would i
argue as an amateur with their their
opinion
but i still feeling very uncomfortable
about the loss of the veteran tree
having built up a bit of knowledge about
their value
um and um you know 300 years is a long
time to survive
and now we're going to plan to get rid
of it possibly on the basis of someone
retaining a
bit of land that they want a lot of
money for to stop the best
development site coming forward um so
that's where that's where my feeling is
um
but yeah can we can we just have an
answer to that one thanks yeah i
wouldn't use the terms ransom strip
or blame i think it's obviously up to an
individual how they choose to
deal with their land ownerships but
kelly would like to comment please
yeah i'm not sure um what sort strips
are available i just know that the
applicant doesn't have the ability to
access the development through this road
which is why they've had to seek other
way and also the land they've got
available is in this corner
and that's the only information i have
available to me at the moment so i'm not
able to go into any more detail
thank you thank you councillor patch
thank you chairman yeah i'd just like to
um echo
a lot of the comments that have been
made about the value of the veteran tree
and um the issue of the loss of that
extremely valuable habitat and amenity
value for local residents uh we've heard
that lots of residents have
expressed concerns about the loss of the
tree but i just want to go back to
the um the potential alternative access
which involved or would involve the
movement of gas pipes
and um the the the argument before that
it would be
um unviable development would be
unviable
um for affordable housing if that
alternative were to be progressed
and i must admit when i hear um the word
sort of viability when it comes to
housing developments i
i have an echo in my mind of
profitability and i just wondered if
there had been
um a a sort of fully or sort of costed
or
or approximate costings for what that
impact would be in terms of the
economics of the development
if if any concrete arguments are put
forward in
in a sense that that might be unviable
to use that alternative access
um just secondly also um
we often hear the argument of a need for
affordable housing
i just wondered the extent of that need
in terms of
has a housing needs survey been
conducted recently and if so what sort
of figures did that um
come up with in terms of true local need
thank you kelly uh thank you councillor
patch
uh yes in terms of the um
the alternative positions for the access
we haven't had costed proposals
the scheme has been through a viability
exercise based on the
32 unit scheme because it was originally
proposed
for 50 market house and 50
affordable housing um but a lot of the
measures that were required in terms of
the mitigation
the landscaping has meant that they
then looked at providing a 100
affordable scheme
so what we'd be looking at is the
applicant now spending time
to obtain ownership
of further land on brickyard lane um
and then they would have to then seek
permissions for
whatever may be required if they can go
over the gas cover or whether it can be
diverted do they need a bridge
and then they would need to go back to
the highway authority and make sure that
they
could achieve whatever the highway story
may require so there are a lot of
unknowns
and an additional cost a time where
um teen housing or or temple homes
have have got to a stage where um
they've already assessed the viability
of the development um
and the and so i think that the delays
and the additional costs that
might arise through going through that
exercise
might jeopardize this development coming
forward and as we say in the report
we have given a lot of weight to the
loss of the tree and it is regrettable
we've looked at a
compensatory replacement planting scheme
which is 35 trees including
replacement oaks and a group of oaks at
the roadside
the scheme has been looked at by our
tree officer
and our landscape officer and they're
both content with the
compensation package to put forward
we've given substantial weight to the
delivery of this housing and therefore
the officer recommendation is that on
balance we should be given more weight
to the provision of affordable housing
here
in terms of housing need we have had
some figures put forward recently by our
housing enablers to say
there is a an urgent and immediate
housing leading star cross
which amounts to about around i don't
have the the specific figures in front
of me but around 13 dwellings
and then in within the secondary areas
there's also a need
so there's definitely need for all 20
that are proposed as part of this fight
within star cross and and within the
secondary area
thank you thank you how's it called
yes chairman thank you um i find this
the most difficult
application to make a decision on
it's a matter of heart and head really
my head goes with the housing which is
obviously needed and
which you know be very happy to see
provided but my heart
goes with the tree and and the effect
that that is going to have it's been
there an
awful long time and it's easy just to
chop it down
so at this minute my heart's going with
it is winning
it's it's on behalf of the tree and what
we're going to do and i can't believe
that there isn't another
alternative for access and way into this
land
without the destruction of that tree
so that's how i feel at the minute
chairman
okay thank you um nobody else has
indicated that they
wish to speak um clearly
it's an issue the the balance of all the
different
um planning matters and the amount of
weight is for members to look at i mean
i'd always be concerned to
go with my head rather than my heart
because that would be a more
rational decision anyway
nobody else is wishing to speak um the
issues i think
members have got clearly before them the
recommendation has been moved and that
was seconded
so that's as it appears on uh page 17
i think it is i'll just bring it back up
on my screen
um it starts on page
17 recommendation that full planning
permission be granted
with the um 106 agreement and then the
conditions under b
uh that's moved and seconded so can i
ask chris to go through please
to do a recorded vote so again you will
be voting for
or against the development taking place
so it's not a negative
okay so let's be moved as set out
permission be granted
chris please mike yeah the
motion is that planning permission be
granted
and it's obviously all the conditions uh
starting on page 17
on the agenda thank you okay chris
please thank you um councillor bradford
against councillor bellevant
councillor clarence councillor cole
clough
against
or counsellor mcgregor
or councillor natal against
councillor natalie with a heavy heart
for
councillor patch angst councillor
governor and bradbury
and councillor haines four
um i have that as 10 4 chair
yeah i've got ten four and five against
so that's carried permission is granted
okay can we move on to the next item
please which is
the um enforcement under
item seven that's land at rebecca
springs now the water
hopefully steve hogsey i can see him on
the screen enforcement officer
um over to you steve
thank you chairman um yeah this i'll
just share my screen
coming up
they're not sharing across
sharing
hey what's happened here i said
sorry how about that there's um this
relates to um
a site uh up at nada water called
rebecca springs which is a collection of
um
buildings it's on the main road going
from
exeter going out towards whitstone um
so this
is a frozen screen of it so sorry about
this
there we go yeah the main road goes from
this is extra side
this is the width downside um the mobile
home is
located just inside here there's a
collection of farm buildings that had
various uses of conversions and that
over the years but
um so this mobile homes here is related
to
this building here that's also subject
of the uh a lot of the information in
the report
that was um originally granted for a
um change of use under um
part p and then um that failed
they failed to do the works within the
time period so that expired
and there's a recent planning
application that was refused but we're
looking really the main idea of was the
use of the mobile home that hasn't got
any consent it's currently occupied by a
family with two children
um contrary to the planning policy
as you see this is a view of the mobile
home
as you sort of just coming in off the
main road
and the actual mobile home itself
is there so order is looking um because
it is occupied
um the report has to go to the planning
committee for the members to
um agree to take enforcement action
because it ultimately will make them
homeless
uh the current occupiers um
i've received additional information
really but it's sort of setting out that
they're
appealing the planning application that
was recently refused but
this is a separate issue and say we need
the authorization to take enforcement
action against the site of the mobile
home that is contrary to planning policy
has set out in the report
okay thank you
back to the normal screen please okay
okay um right council nato
is the world member
so not all are you
i'm sorry i i didn't realize that was
actually in my ward i beg your pardon
um um
i don't think i have any substantive
comment at the moment
okay i'll make a few observations myself
then so
clearly the on that's
mentioned in the agenda um has gone to
appeal
um if we take enforcement action on this
caravan then that gives the opportunity
for the appeal
uh to be made on that and to be heard at
the same time
the issue would be of course currently
living in a caravan
previously in anticipation of moving
into the barn when it was converted but
that's not happened
we've had the caravan now on site for
three years
uh eventually there is an issue of
course of having to take
an enforcement action in order to
safeguard
the land use and it doesn't become uh an
established use on site
uh so those are the the issues and to my
mind i think it will be
more straightforward to take enforcement
action
and for that to be considered also when
uh the appeal
on the barn is taken but i'll let others
express their views now had a chance to
think about it council mcgregor
thank you chair um i just want to ask
if in a situation where we're likely to
go for enforcement action that um we
have somewhere for this family to go to
um i'm reluctant at any stage to evict a
family and make them homeless
under any circumstances and going from
previous uh other um enforcement actions
that the the
the council has taken um
or not taken on the basis of of uh the
fact that we make people homeless
vulnerable people homeless as well
um i think we need to we need to be
clear that if we are going to take
enforcement action that's going to lead
to somebody's homelessness that we
actually have a
location for them to be moved to before
any decision is made on enforcement
that's that would be my comment thank
you
yeah i think we'd all be concerned about
that that's the reason why
enforcement items of that nature have to
come to committee
um i'll take the other speakers
counselor patch
thank you chair
i like councillor mcgregor and i'm sure
um like many members i would feel very
uncomfortable
with um playing a part and making a
family with children homeless
um at this time especially but at any
time really
and i i just i'm just thinking about the
fact that this barn um that's
sort of tied in with this application um
this issue this enforcement issue i
think at some point we here had planning
commission and um it lapsed i would
think it
not unreasonable that that buyer might
again in the future
um obtain planning permission
and i i just taking that into account
the broader picture i see this different
as somebody who's just
um sort of like squatting if you like on
a piece of land
out of the context that we've seen and i
would feel very uncomfortable actually
sort of taking in any action that would
lead to
um that family with children being made
homeless
thank you councilman
thank you um i understand that the
reason of the planning or they fail to
take up the
planning consent on the conversion of
the building is the cause of the
issue it is likely to go once playing
consent has been given it's
likely to get reaffirmed that that
building would be used for
uh residential use so i'm therefore very
concerned
that um what we don't do is put a family
out on the streets
um as soon as our appeal goes to on the
building should it be granted then
a person having a caravan next to it so
while they do the work is would be
perfectly allowable i'm
i just think we've got to be careful
here that we protect the
individuals involved in the house until
the decision is known
what's going to happen to the bond
conversion um
whilst we're saying that i don't agree
with this or would like to create a
situation where because of lack of
action
that they move to a position where it
becomes
typical factor that they get permission
for the caravan to be on site
so your recommendation i believe covered
those uh
aspects uh chet i'm very happy to get
behind the
suggestions that you made and support
you in that
proposal thank you i didn't actually
make a proposal i i was just explaining
what my
what my view was i clearly if
and and this has happened on many
occasions over
over the years those have been on
planning committee for longer we'll
will know that this is is always the the
concern that
gets raised if we were to go for
enforcement
action today then the people living
there would be able to appeal against
that
as they are currently appealing the the
planning
application and refusal for the bond um
as and when the inspector hears the
appeal
the inspector would then obviously would
have the option of approving the bar
or not and then they would have the
option
of what to do about the enforcement on
the caravan
but they would give a period of time
to allow for the occupants of the
caravan to find alternative
accommodation
and the length of time uh would
certainly be you know sort of
nearer to a year i would think from
experience certainly over six months
more than that uh and even then after
that
if the people are unable to find
anywhere to move they would still
uh be there and it would only be if the
council was to actually go to
call to action to to seek the
enforcement through that route that we
will be looking at
things getting nearer to a conclusion
i don't know whether steve hobbs wants
to add anything
or correct me on that but certainly it's
a long process and you're not today
saying that these people aren't going to
be without somewhere to live certainly
for the next year i would think
that yeah
as part of the enforcement notice we
would be giving a period of 12 months
for compliance anyway so that wouldn't
actually so
if an appeal is made against the
enforcement notice it holds everything
in the vayance
while the inspector looks at both
enforcement notice and the planning
application
and then should the application be
approved then they
would be entitled to carry out the works
themselves and beyond there uh
they're able to stay there if it's
refused and the enforcement nurse
notices upheld
the 12-month period comes into effect at
that stage so they would still have 12
months
once the appeal was being made and they
could then contact the council's housing
department at an early stage which
they'd been
encouraged to do and hopefully then
within that 12 month period
the the matter would be resolved
thank you all right the issue is that as
i think council bulletin said if we
don't
um actually take action on these things
and eventually they get
the established use and so you end up
with lots of uh
unplanned uh new dwellings across the
district
okay anyone else wish to say anything
everyone cleared on the issues
i'll i'll move then the recommendation
um so that
members are clear what we're going to be
doing it's it's the recommendation at
the start of that part of the report and
enforcement notice be issued um
and then it's um obviously in the event
of that not being complied with
authorization
to take further action it doesn't give
the 12 months in that
um mr hobbs so uh
well so it does i think the
recommendation is the
committee's recommended resolve to serve
an enforcement notice seating and the
period the compliance period for both
is recommended to be 12 months so that's
a bit above it so
it's a cease to use and remove the
caravan in a 12 month period
okay okay well that's that's what i'll
move is that seconded
council bolivar the second adapt okay
nobody else wishing to speak in which
case can i ask
for chris to go and take the recorded
vote please
thank you chair um councillor bradford
against councillor bullavant
wall councillor clarence bort
councillor colclough councillor cox
or councillor hayes
councillor hook councillor jeffrey
councillor caswell
councilman mcgregor abstain
counselor nuttall i shall also be
staying please
counselor nutley abstain
counselor patch
gates counselor goodman bradbury
and councillor haynes
um that's carried chair i think it's is
it
eleven two and two no i've got
nine four two against and four
abstentions
okay and that in perry is not in there
so
um it's carried nine votes so
enforcement action
as outlined to proceed on that
that particular plot right thank you
we're moving on then
to the final item which is item eight
the appeal decisions
uh to be noted um i don't think there's
anything
to say on those or any any points
that the officer has anything to to
mention on those
okay so there for noting so in that case
then we've got to the end of today's
business so thank you all very much
for your involvement in that and i look
forward to seeing you
uh in some form at our next meeting in
may
and i'll see council meetings before
then so thank you very much and
feel free to log off now
thanks mike thank you
um i think trish is